john has this um
this little
this little
cancer
scam thing going on or at least that's
what everybody thinks it is at least
that's what it kind of appears to be
let me see if i can find the og video
because i know i sent it to royce
originally
well hello everybody welcome to the
stuttering john podcast with your
favorite host stuttering john melendez
not our favorite uh okay let me just
address this
one of our beloved
chatters
loved one is going through expensive ass
chemo
you know as opposed to that cheap chemo
chosen to remain anonymous
paypal
donation will go to help
pay for the chemo
so anything that you send to me
through paypal
i promise will go
directly
to that person i have so many problems
with this for one it's illegal
two
the tax burden john
i've always made it implicitly clear i
will not raise money for anybody
i will happily promote something if
you've got it if somebody in our
community is going through something bad
you want to make a gofundme you want to
i will i'll you know give you a shout
out and stuff but i'm not collecting
money i'm not
i'm not abs i'm not a [ __ ]
i'm not gonna [ __ ] you know basically
take on the burden of taxes for you for
your problems
um
most people obviously believe that this
is not the case there is no fan with a
problem uh again it's it's
even if the fan
wanted to remain anonymous that fan
could have made a gofundme or as royce
brought up today you could have made a
gofundme
that shows that the money's not going to
you
and it's going to some anonymous third
party
and gofundme would do the due diligence
and then they would do it that way but
this is
dude there's no way to account for this
john sometimes i get random paypals
it's rare
but occasionally people go to paypal dot
me slash merge comedy whatevs
revenge of assist.com nightwave john
sometimes people don't donate coffee
sometimes they don't want to donate
crypto sometimes people have paypal and
they throw you a couple tree bucks now
there have been times i wasn't even live
john there've been times it was a
saturday afternoon and i got 25 bucks on
paypal from a fan that was just like hey
you know what
[ __ ] do you
do you immerse go have a nice [ __ ]
dinner tonight and it's like you're not
even live you just get a [ __ ]
notification and you go oh
well that's cool thanks
but like
like how would you separate those from
like the cancer ones or like
i would never
i would never use my paypal and mix it
up into some pot with a bunch of other
people's stuff like that sounds hellish
john even our business even rotc
is [ __ ] separate it is not me none of
them you know what i mean even when i
started having my little problems with
the irs this year didn't matter we had
already been audited we were already
[ __ ] compliant we never had a problem
you know what i mean the irs ended up
owing us like [ __ ] four grand
so they were like you know
whatever
but like they're separate streams of
income it's clean
nice and clean
so that there's no issues so that if
royce has problems it doesn't affect the
company if the company has problems it
doesn't affect the both of us if i got
my own [ __ ] problems they don't
affect royce in a bit you know what i
mean john
i bet john doesn't even have an llc
john you probably don't have an llc this
money's like oh my god i couldn't i
couldn't imagine if i was like hey guys
we got a beloved chatter in the audience
so donate to the revenge of this is
paypal and uh we'll give all the money
to them
like i'd go to work i'd go to [ __ ] do
the show next week and race would be
like do you need a [ __ ] cat scan like
what is wrong with you
i have done
everything that i can do and
this is just something else that i can
do
so if you want to help
fine if you can't afford to
find
maybe one day
i'll be able to tell you who it is
but right now
they have chosen
for me not to reveal
who they are that doesn't sound [ __ ]
someone that we all
hey listen guys i know i've just
recently had some troubles
by the way john has recently had some
troubles he's selling his condo and i
think he's trying to get another place
and i think he's trying to a couple
people at the dabblers anonymous uh
reddit
are convinced
that john is trying to squeeze some
money for this this new mortgage
but um
guys listen i know that you heard about
my stories as i get all the vet bills
i'm trying to get a new apartment
i got the [ __ ] little car issue
that's going on but i want you guys to
put all that out of your brain right now
we got a
a
beloved chatter
who's
got the answer and uh i want everybody
to
donate
to my buy me a coffees all my coffees
are gonna go to
cancer
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um
i will say this though i want to promote
this real quick because i know we do we
do at we do actually have up
love
chatter
that is uh going through some [ __ ] and i
did promise that i would uh share this
you guys know all know toasty um i
believe she's in the chat right now she
does have a gofundme right now uh she
had some
[Music]
uh
an assault
take place that was uh unpleasant
and uh
[ __ ] sort of i'm not gonna get into all
this stuff you guys can read the story
because i don't know what i can share
what i can't but uh you know her from
doctor till stream and you know her from
all around and stuff she is actually
doing a gofundme which does not go to my
paypal
i want to make that clear
um that is her paypal so if you guys
want to help her out obviously we all
love her um but let you know that's
that's
[Music]
daddy piece what happened to her i'll
let her tell this story man that's not
my story to tell
um but i wanted to make sure that i
promoted that because you know she is
part of the fam
fam
so
john's been
so bent out of shape about this
and it started with anthony coomey
making fun of him and carl from who are
these podcasts and now john's getting
pissed and he's saying he's going to sue
people
hang on what what vile
these are scumbags as we say in germany
yeah yeah i'll text them to you dean
okay please don't yeah i don't want to
kill you
yeah
wow yeah
yeah i definitely know who they are
at least one of them the other one maybe
not
one has money or the other no you're
going with money everybody if you're
gonna assume pick the one with money so
of course he's talking about anthony and
carl i'm going to sue anthony and i'm
going to sue carl for more of these
podcasts
um
john you got you you you're feeling very
confident for a guy who's doing
something that on paper is illegal
even if you're trying to give the money
to them or whatever john you're a
[ __ ] idiot so even if you genuinely
try to give all the money to this person
you're gonna [ __ ] bungle it you're
gonna forget you're gonna forget to
carry a one or something and guess
what's gonna happen you're gonna get
yourself in trouble you're drawing more
attention to
your own troubles
and and also let me i also want to make
it known that um anthony kumia i'm sure
he's got a few bucks left but anthony is
not
sitting on the
throne of money that he was when he was
working consistently at sirius
on the flip side
carl's not like poor
you know what i mean like i don't
i i certainly don't know where you're
getting that impression
uh that that that carl from who are
these podcasts is is living hand to
mouth he's just [ __ ] struggling
eating scoops of peanut butter and ramen
just to survive john i don't i mean carl
i don't think carl's a billionaire or
anything
but i
the fact that he like what one's got
money the the other day he's the other
one's poor
you want to get the money look you if
the money is not because you're greedy
the money the theory of the money in our
legal system is to make you a whole for
your loss so you were injured you were
damaged yes reputation or if you get
hurt in a car accident chuck norris at
dino vidal this is supposed to be a
celebrity guest look john gets who he
can get emotionally damaged by this d
you were long emotionally damaged but
yes this is another
see they're trying to have a little fun
with it
but uh john's not having fun with it
because he went on a [ __ ] tangent
about this
by the way uh depending on what's going
on with dreadworks drug drug works
tomorrow or what's going on i don't know
i might do a show tomorrow night
because god knows i need the money right
now so
might be a night wave tomorrow things on
a serious
serious
um
you okay
issue okay
as you know
last week or the week before that i
can't remember
i had been saying that a certain person
a beloved person
in this chat
has
a spouse
that
is undergoing very expensive chemo
treatment i thought he was getting the
chemo treatments now
i
happen to know this person and converse
with this person
but this person has asked me
to not mention
his or her name
which
i of course would never do that
now i've
said that i would
give any of my paypal donations
to this person
which
can only be viewed
as a kind gesture
for
someone that i care about he's a good
man right john you're a good man john
any normal person on this planet and i
underline normal
would consider this to be a kind gesture
on my part
and i don't even view it as something to
pat myself on the back about because i
would do it time and time again because
that's the person i am that's what i am
made of and anybody who knows me will
tell you the same damn thing
john a lot of people say you owe them
money
john
a lot of people in the industry have
stories of borrowing money from you and
never getting it back
i've had some of them
recalled recanted to me personally by
comedians from the new york area how you
grifted a bunch of them
john
you're not known as being you're not the
mother teresa of the [ __ ] howard
stern show i don't know where you think
he got this rap and also the way he's
like any normal person would just see me
doing good and leave me alone
but john
not believing you doesn't mean that
we're [ __ ] up it's not like like john
is trying to sell this on people is like
these people are slandering me
john
it's not that we're slandering you it's
that many of us don't believe you and
also
even if you're doing this righteously
you're you're still doing something
you're not supposed to be doing
and it doesn't look good
it just doesn't look good homie
but
we have
people
that are trying to get me in some kind
of trouble no no no no no no no we have
people that don't believe you and are
trying to hold you accountable
but that's what we have
we have people who know
what a scumbag you are
and are simply
arriving at the most
logical
conclusion because i'm not allowed to
have a charity
no you're not you have to i mean you are
but
john
[Laughter]
john
technically anyone's allowed to have a
charity
but
there's
steps that one is
meant to
undertake
when one
wants to be a charity right you can't
just uh
anyway continue john i'm sorry you keep
getting me sidetracked johnny the
charity i've already talked to my
attorney about this
there's nothing they could do
but i talked to the person and he or she
said
buddy your attorney takes nothing but
l's just like you do
you took an l from sirius you took an l
from howard stern you're gonna take an l
from carl from whoever these podcasts
you're gonna take an l from cumia
you took an l for me and royce
how many [ __ ] l's do you have
jon just stop it i don't want anybody
you to get in any trouble
it's okay
i'll get by
so i'm not gonna say i'm giving it to
anybody but if you want to donate
you may
and whatever i do that money is all up
to me oh well because you're covering
your ass now
then
some lunatic
had
john you just got yourself in more
trouble by saying that
the audacity
to slander me
on cj says they took the bp off the flea
market it's hard to get more than 30 at
a time
did they take that off
same
hey buddy that i am pocketing
this money
now
the person who
i have been trying to help knows
that is not the case
in fact is that supposed to be los
angeles behind you
another person in this chat
knows
that is not the case
since i then mowed
the entire amount plus some that i
received john you're going to end up in
the hole that way you have to pay the
taxes on
the money you're receiving and then it's
going to pile up and then you're going
to have this [ __ ] let's say people
give you five grand
you know what i mean
for this cancer thing that's [ __ ] you
know five six hundred you're gonna wanna
put off to the side
just to be safe for the [ __ ] tax
to
a person in this chat because the person
undergoing the chemo
uh spouse they don't use they pay power
oh we're using the pronouns now they
them they them
first it was him then it was his spouse
now it's they them
so i
did it to a mutual friend gave and then
he
and then he okay so john which one of
the 147
people watching you has debilitating
cancer and doesn't want to come forward
and doesn't want to accept any public
help and he's going to let you raise
money through your
paypal
which one because one of these 147
people i would think is the beloved
beloved chatter
who is you know would be he's beloved
she probably never misses a show so out
of
146 other marks that you can get to chip
in
and give money to this guy
or girl or they them they are
metal npc goes 146 soon
that's mean
everybody's saying now too he's
literally
uh stone malone he's literally
describing money laundering goofy boots
is he really admitting to money
laundering accidentally
that's john i wrote the check to the
person
who
respected the person what happened and
then he
wrote the check to the person i missed
that part that's money laundering
so you're ven mowing money
to somebody
who's supposedly maybe royce is right
maybe he's getting scammed
he's either scanning or he's getting
scammed john so you're you're taking
your paypal donations you're sending it
via venmo to a guy who's then gonna
write a check
to his spouse
so she can get they them can get k
um
i i've missed out on the whole thing to
be honest with you i was confused by it
i'm very confused by the i was very
confused by the whole thing to be if i'm
being honest
why would you need to write it like i
wouldn't
that i would find that fishy it's like
somebody's like you venmo me the money
then i'll write a check to my wife
ryan virgi and i lose my [ __ ] paypal
over nothing
welcome to america
we need a flow chart you're right
somebody should draw a john flow chart
goofy boots john male fraud has a 95
conviction right
stoned malone someone who john owes
money to is scamming him knowing it's
the only way to get paid by john that's
a good point
homer's war rocks this seems like a long
process for an ipad to watch while in
chemo
is
going through this disaster
now
getting back to this person who decided
to slander me i've already talked to my
attorney
look
you can't be saying
that i'm doing something nefarious
and unlawful
there are ramifications for that kind of
speech
legal
ramifications
for that kind of speech
so i suggest you retract it
because if you think i'm here to play
around with y'all goddammit
john trying to talk tough because
i
as you know
i follow the law
have never been arrested
and
will only proceed through legal
channels
that's
how i do it when sharon stone's
bodyguard beat the [ __ ] out of me
i sued sharon stone and i won
you didn't win she settled right now i
am in a pr i am in
a lawsuit with siriusxm you already lost
that lawsuit it's in appeals it's going
to lose there as well
i am not it's meritless not afraid to
sue
so when you go on your show you stupid
[ __ ]
and start slandering me
saying that i am pocketing
some money
that
you [ __ ] twit
is slanderous
it's untrue
but it's harmful to my reputation
that's
reputation stupid
shut up
shut up shut up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah it's jealousy i need help combating
the jealous
you're ruining his reputation guys hey
hey
listen to me
dennis michaels and all you little
[ __ ] all you little [ __ ] scumbags
over it's dabblers anonymous
if there's one thing i want to see you
all stop doing right now for your own
good
is to stop dragging
the name of john melendez through the
muck
i won't have it boys
i will not be associated with those
criminals at dabbler's anonymous if
they're going to continue to just
slander a good man's name like this
you're hurting his reputation dennis he
spent [ __ ] years building up one of
the most
[ __ ]
established
reputations and track records in
hollywood
and he won't have you but
mess it up for him
to whatever businesses
i shall proceed in
it is slander
so
that's that
legal process the other one
as i tweeted out today
this friday coming up i have a
conference call
with a certain streaming service well
i'll just say it patreon
with my lawyer and there they're not a
streaming service john legal team
they're
more of a paywall thing but oh gosh
because there's another show
that
is okay with using the r word calling me
the r word
okay we're trashing my children
is that uh which one is that
is that who are these podcasts
or is it uh or is it ann
okay with giving away
perks on his discord
with people posting n words
oh you're going after carlos oh
johnny boy we're in cancel club now
is that right john
we're going after people's patreons now
is that what we're doing
oh john
oh john
oh stop
the [ __ ] scratching
stop
lay down
um
buddy
you're gonna make a lot of enemies that
way
and you say a lot of [ __ ] too
and you got a lot of copyrighted [ __ ] on
your channel too
you got a lot of [ __ ] skeletons in
your little closet buddy
you don't want to [ __ ] stephen to be
going careful johnny that's a two-way
street
[Laughter]
careful bud
easy buddy yes stephen defeat goes
careful johnny that's a two-way cheat
now
once it once you do it then it's okay
then it's [ __ ] open season on you val
jon once you start hitting those all
those channels that are critical to you
once you start once you start [ __ ]
dmca and all this [ __ ] you're gonna
ah be careful be careful johnny boy
because carl bounced back just fine
but you're gonna get skull [ __ ] into
oblivion
kerry c says nobody likes john as it is
he's really going to crack open that
closet of skeletons i know seriously
dennis michaels john is just in the
worthy podcast discord there is a
dabbler's one where the beer on the
balcony is distributed and promoted oh
so
whatever
semitism anti-hispanic i mean i would
zap that if i would zap that channel if
i was soon but i mean there's other ways
to share links hate racism but losing
your discord i'm gonna lose you your
patreon threats of violence so it was me
and my family
so
we'll see how that threats of violence
yeah i remember all those funny times
carl from who are these podcasts
threatening to kill your kids works on
friday
and i thank jack conte for making this
happen
and thank you for the [ __ ] thank you
for dming me
the [ __ ] is jack conte
now
there is the link
if you want to donate
to me
so i could continue to do this show
and by the way you know the person
whose spouse is going through chemo
this person said to me
john
i could really use
an ipad
an apple product
so my
love
can
play games
you know what john you're such a holy
angel you're such a sweet holy angel
um can we get some like nice like choir
music for john there we go
saint john everybody
saint john to me
[Music]
so i could continue to do this show
and by the way you know the person
whose spouse is going through chemo
[Music]
this person said to me
john
i could really use hang on
hang on hang on hang on i know what this
is missing
there we go
oh there we go saint john
here we go saint john
i'm sorry st john tell us more about
this ipad again
to do this show
and by the way you know the person
whose spouse is going through chemo
this person said to me
john
i could really use
an ipad
an apple product
so my
love
can
play games here we go converse with me
while he's undergoing the hours of chemo
treatment
what did i do
i got one
with my own money
and mailed it to this person
oh my god that's what i did
all praise saint john
all you people
who wanna pound on me
they're doing something kind
what does that say about you
i ask you oh yes suffering saint
melendez
[Laughter]
if your loved one was going through
a horrible
health situation
when you try and help
[Music]
would you pocket the money you [ __ ]
[ __ ] this syncs up good
no
no would i
[Music]
look
trump has made it okay to hate donald
trump
nice nice [ __ ] stretch people like to
bring up
something
that howard did or i did or already did
or jackie did over 30 years ago on the
stern show well guess what the world's
changed we have changed
words have changed
that was over 30 years ago this is 20
[ __ ] 22.
we know what is right and we know what
is wrong
[Music]
it is amazing
that's their only defense well
john was on a show that did this with
howard 30 years ago
and then
we didn't deem it
as inappropriate i know howard didn't
[ __ ] howard was in blackface
do i think howard's a racist no
[Music]
all those years ago and even if you go
back five years words have changed yeah
it's stupid now 2020. it's dumb
it should stop i don't know what words
shorty one how are you
[Music]
there it is that's the end thank you
saint john
ah
thank you
patriot saint of cancer scams
john melendez